according to the ich gcp guidelines
there are three key roles in the
clinical trial process
the ethics committee representing the
regulatory authority
the sponsor initiating and financing the
project
and the investigator conducts the
research
the ichcp defines the investigator as a
person responsible for the conduct of
the clinical trial site
if a trial is conducted by a team of
individuals at a trial site
the investigator is the responsible
leader of the team and may be called the
principal investigator co-investigator
is a term that predates the ich
gcp it has subsequently been replaced by
the term sub-investigator
the ich gcp defines sub-investigator as
any individual member of the clinical
trial designated and supervised by the
investigator at a trial site to perform
critical trial related procedures
or make important trial related
decisions
these may include associates residents
or research fellows
in a clinical trial the responsibilities
of an investigator generally include
protecting the rights safety and welfare
of subjects in the clinical study
ensuring that informed consent is
properly obtained from clinical trial
subjects conducting the clinical study
and directly overseeing the
administration of the test products to
the subject
in situations where there is a team of
researchers the investigator will act as
the team leader ensuring that the
clinical trial is conducted in
accordance with the signed agreement and
the investigational plan
controlling the products under
investigation including supervising
medical device use and disposal
and ensuring proper record-keeping and
reporting requirements are met for
example
mandatory safety reporting
in the conduct of a clinical trial a
sponsor is an individual
institution company or organization that
takes the responsibility to initiate
manage or finance the clinical trial but
does not actually conduct the
investigation
the specific requirements for a clinical
study sponsor can vary
generally a sponsor is responsible for
selecting the investigators providing
investigators with the necessary
information to conduct the clinical
trial
ensuring proper monitoring of the
clinical study
ensuring all the necessary ethic reviews
and approvals are obtained
preparing and submitting clinical trial
applications and amendments to the
appropriate regulatory agencies
ensuring that any reviewing ethics board
and regulatory agencies are promptly
informed of any significant new
information
for example important findings that
affect product safety
ensuring compliance with labeling
reporting and record keeping
requirements
refraining from engaging in promotional
activities and other prohibited
activities
such as commercializing an
investigational medical device
and ensuring that the clinical study is
conducted in accordance with good
clinical practice
in a clinical trial the responsibilities
of an investigator generally include
protecting the rights safety and welfare
of subjects in the clinical study
ensuring that informed consent is
properly obtained from clinical trial
subjects
conducting the clinical study and
directly overseeing the administration
of the test products to the subject
in situations where there is a team of
researchers the investigator will act as
the team leader
ensuring that the clinical trial is
conducted in accordance with the signed
agreement
and the investigational plan controlling
the products under investigation
including supervising medical device use
and disposal and ensuring proper record
keeping and reporting requirements are
met
for example mandatory safety reporting
sponsor investigators also generally
need to manage the following
securing funding for the clinical trial
applying for the appropriate insurance
generating the appropriate clinical
trial documentation
for example informed consent protocols
and submissions for example
ethics and or regulatory submissions
ensuring adequate resources are
available for the duration of the trial
for example
experienced staff investigational and
control products
clinical and medical supplies and
analytical laboratory
creating appropriate written procedures
for example
standard operating procedures related to
gcp
and meeting all the applicable
regulatory requirements such as
obtaining and maintaining necessary
approvals from the relevant ethics
review boards and regulatory agencies
in summary the management of sponsor and
investigator relationship
is of central importance for planning
and executing clinical trials
you